I worked for GE for six years and I had
studied the Wharton School of Business
beforehand before entering GE and after
about six years I started to realize
that this really wasn't for me you know
business was a real vocation as it were
for a lot of my friends and I just got
more and more miserable you know the
work lo got more difficult as anyone who
works in the corporate world knows that
can be really stressful and I saw some
friends of mine really enjoying the work
while I just seemed to get bored by it
at the same time I was getting all these
stomach problems and sort of
stress-related illnesses one night I
came home dead tired after this long day
of work and I sort of plopped down in
our couch and turned on the TV and there
was his PBS documentary about the guy
named Thomas Merton it was a Trappist
monk a cloistered monk and I had never
heard of him and the documentary really
just captivated me the look on his face
just just spoke this great sense of joy
and peace and calm and consolation and
it really called out to me and that was
so interesting that one documentary that
I went out and purchased his
autobiography the seven-story mountain
which is pretty well known in Catholic
circles I'd never heard of it I devoured
it I read it in a couple of nights and I
really couldn't get it out of my mind
that that's what I wanted to do
something like what he did I didn't I
wasn't particularly religious I was
Catholic but I wasn't super kath like I
never thought of anything like that
before and I read a lot about Thomas
Merton and one day I went up to my
parish priest and I said you know i
think i'd be interested in being a
priest which was kind of weird because
he had never even you know met me before
and he said well you know you should
talk to the local diocese and you might
want to talk to the Jesuits who were up
the street at Fairfield University in
Connecticut that was the only connection
I had to the Jesuits so I visited the
Jesuits at Fairfield they gave me some
you know vocational literature kind of
promotional literature about the Jesuits
and I read it and I thought this is
crazy you know actually ripped it up
threw it away and thought this is insane
you know this is not this is not who I
am but you know I read some more and and
continued to read around the same time I
started to go to a psychologist because
of all these stress-related stomach
problems as a result of work and so I'm
reading and thinking and going to the
psychologist at the same time and
finally one day he said to me well you
know you're in this business world you
don't seem very happy so what would you
do if you could do anything you wanted
to do and I thought for a moment and I
said oh I'd be a Jesuit priest and he
said well why don't you and I thought
yeah why don't I so it made sense and I
thought well this is really something
that I'm actually interested in why am i
doing something that I dislike you know
so i called the Jesuits and they didn't
who i was and i said i'm ready to enter
and they were nice enough to sort of
start me on the application process
which took a couple months but a couple
months later I was in so it was pretty
rushed but I just say looking back on it
it was probably well it was the best
decision I've ever made
well I have to say st. ignatius loyola
the founder of the Jesuits who live from
1491 to 1556 you know his spirituality
which can be summarized as finding God
in all things or being a contemplative
in action the person who is has a sense
of awareness in the midst of a very busy
world has really changed the way I live
my life I think you know for me said
Ignatius ha's is kind of the model for
all Jesuits but I don't just like Jesuit
saints i also like st. Therese of
Lisieux who was a 19th century Carmelite
nun who lived what she called her little
way which was basically doing small
things with great love for god I love
Blessed John the 23rd who was Pope from
nineteen fifty eight to nineteen sixty
three because he was so funny basically
one joke from John the twenty-third a
journalist asked him once how many
people work in the Vatican and he said
about half of them you know so I mean he
shows you can be someone with a sense of
humor and be a saint and then finally
Thomas Merton the fellow whose book i
read who kind of got it me started on
religious life so those are my I'd say
top four
you don't need to believe in God to find
his insights useful it helps to
understand the totality of his message
because Jesuit spirituality without God
or without Jesus you know will only make
partial sense but that being said st.
Ignatius knew that people were on
different paths in their life you know
to God and different paths in general
and so many of the insights are really
useful to people who are not only
developed believers but even doubtful
seekers people who are agnostic or
atheist for example he talks about how
to make decisions living freely how to
be a good friend how to work well how to
be in a healthy relationship with
somebody so there's a lot of things that
you can take from the way of st.
Ignatius that are applicable to anybody
but really to understand it in its
totality you have to see it as sort of a
path to God so I like to say that anyone
can benefit from the way of sand
Ignatius but to get to the final end you
really do have to keep your eyes focused
on god
a lot of ignatian spirituality talks
about desire and that's sort of a bad
word in some spiritual circles because
some people equate it with just selfish
once right like I want a new car I want
a new iphone I want a new pc something
like that or they think of it a sexual
desire which is you know oh my gosh god
forbid we should talk about sexual
desire I mean that's that's healthy
right but desire on an even deeper level
is the desire that we have to be who we
are to be our true selves and the desire
for God and there's also desires that
lead us to our vocations and what we
want to do in life so for example a
married couple might discover their
vocations through desire so the desire
for sexual intimacy for emotional
intimacy for a of connectedness that
mean that brings them together people
understand that in terms of desire
desire works the same way in terms of
our jobs and our vocations someone who
is interested in video might be
interested in it because they feel this
attraction to it it's really interesting
they feel this desire for it someone
who's a doctor might find talking about
medicine and and the body and things
like that just really attractive so so
desires a really important thing to to
pay attention to and ultimately our
desires I believe our deepest desires
are God's desires for us really and and
the deepest desires we have to be our
true self to really live out who were
meant to be and what we're meant to do
are the ways that God has of drawing us
to happiness and also ways that God has
of drawing us I think to fulfill God's
desires for the world so I don't think
we should be to our desire in the
spiritual life or in any part of life
yeah I don't think we can find true
happiness you know this side of life
from there's always going to be certain
suffering and struggles everybody has
problems in her life but I think you can
attain a great sense of joy and peace if
your life is centered on God now that
sounds really cheesy what does that mean
it means in the ignition way of looking
at things the Jesuit way of looking at
things a lot of freedom and detachment
from things that keep you from being
connected to God it means of being
grateful for the things that our
blessings in your life means as a
contemplatin being aware of all the
blessings you have in life but a certain
amount of suffering is inevitable in
anyone's life I think any religion any
really healthy religion will tell you
that so you know full joy i think is
only achieved with God you know in the
afterlife God willing but I think you
can experience a lot of joy in your life
today on earth thank God